all right so thanks Emma um yeah
so I'm excited to tell you a little bit
about the work that my group's been
doing on getting robots to be able to
learn how to do things from people just
a since it's a broad audience a little
bit of my background as I did my PhD at
the Media Lab at MIT working with
Cynthia Brazil on cute little robots
like this one and then I went to Georgia
Tech and had a great group of students
and we were working on these robots that
I'll have a lot in my talk and now I'm
at the University of Texas at Austin in
the ECE department building up a new lab
so I my lab is called the socially
intelligent machines lab and we are
generally interested in getting robots
out into the world interacting with
people in human environments and so you
know this is just a smattering of the
kinds of robots that we think about and
the kinds of human environments and the
kind of interactions that we think about
and our main premise is that we're
interested in these social robots we're
social to us means any robot that has to
interact with a human as part of its
functional goal so it's going to be out
in human environments interacting with
people as part of what it has to get
done so one of the things that's true
about these human environments is that a
lot of the successes of robots are in
these structured environments where you
can learn something or model something
and do it over and over and be
successful but human environments are
messy and dynamic and pre-programming
the exact thing ahead of time is going
to be hard so we like to think about how
robots are going to be able to learn how
to do the right thing on the job out in
the world from end users so that's sort
of our premise and so one example that
motivates this is in the manufacturing
domain so people are interested in
getting robots to be able to be flexible
co-workers in these manufacturing spaces
so you know currently you see robots and
manufacturing
doing your building airplanes or cars or
things where you can set up the process
and it's the same process for a very
long time but if you're a small or
medium size manufacturing operation you
may want to have the robot do one thing
this week and another thing the next
week and so this is this motivation for
having robots that can learn how to do
new things on the manufacturing line and
so the one example that everyone can be
familiar with is you want to have a
robot that's going to clean your messy
kitchen that is hopefully not as messy
as the images you got when you google
messy kitchen but every person's home is
slightly different so I can't and you
know I can't sit in my lab and program
exactly what the robot should do when
it's going to clean up your kitchen you
have to interact with the end user and
get some part of your parameterization
or some part of their your skill set on
the job from end users so this is what
we like to think about is you know how
do we get end-users to come into our lab
and teach our robots how to do stuff and
you know what are the right interactions
for these end users and what kind of
what does their data what is the input
that they give our learning algorithm
what does it look like and you know can
we change anything about the interaction
can we change anything about the
algorithm to kind of make these two
things mesh a little better and so I'll
tell you a little bit about some of the
results that we have so we're interested
in what the data looks like and whether
we can facilitate better demonstrations
so here's an example from quite a while
ago but this is our robot Simon and
somebody's teaching this robot how to
close this box
and this is a pretty standard approach
in robot learning from demonstrations it
would get demonstration from and a
teacher as to what you're supposed to be
doing but this is you know after this
person has had a whole practice session
about how to use this robot and how to
teach it they're still having trouble
you know figuring out how to move the
the joints and it wasn't until you know
one of my grad students at the time Maya
check mech came and you know you know
try moving it this way and so the
problem is that the robot was recording
the entire thing and you know so the
demonstration goes you know okay start
recording and now I'm recording the
whole thing and I recorded all of this
stuff of messing with the arm and and so
that's not ideal in terms of input space
for a machine learning algorithm that's
gonna then try to recreate that whole
thing so what we've been looking at is
an alternative demonstration where we
just get keyframes from the person and
so a little bit like this so same skill
so each time he says record frame we
take a snapshot of the state and I'll
get into the details and a little bit
about what is actually recording and
here you see that you know he's kind of
having similar sorts of issues figuring
out exactly the kinematics and he'd like
to you know put the robot into to get
the skill done but the benefit is we're
not recording all of this we're kind of
letting the user figure out what they
want to hold what state they would like
to record and then recording it so this
is a demonstration technique that we've
made that is a good way to get people
that aren't very good at demonstrating
skills to have better data so the
trajectory information you know good
teachers are better at providing
trajectories if you know exactly how you
want the robot to do something and and
you're good at providing it then taking
all of that trajectory information is
useful because we get we get velocity
information so we can communicate the
speed and and whereas these keyframe
demonstrations you're stopping every
time so we don't get any information
about what the desired velocity is out
those stopping points but but if if
instead if you're giving me trajectories
that have all of this extraneous
information I would much rather throw
away some of that velocity information
and further that later and take just the
keyframe demonstrations so we've been
making a lot of use of of keyframes and
that's going to be the input dem
demonstration type for for most of the
rest of this talk and a lot of students
that are in my lab have kind of taken
and developed different aspects of what
we might do with this information that
is keyframes where we're thinking about
keyframes in the visual space keyframes
in the the motor space key frames in the
haptic force feedback space and one
observation I'm gonna tell you about I'm
gonna focus mostly on oh I don't have a
picture of barish I'm focused mostly on
one students work barish Atkin who's
looking at exactly how we should
learned from keyframe based learning
from demonstration and one of the things
that really motivated bearishness
work on keyframe demonstration is this
early example that we saw when we are
still using trajectories and so I'll
show you this really old video of the
pr2
and and here we're still closing this
box and the pr2 is recording a
trajectory and this person has this
teleoperation device so it's controlling
the pr2 via teleoperation and it's
recording the whole trajectory and
you're trying to get the pr2 to close
this box which is even when you're
sitting right next to it this
teleoperation is very hard to do it's
really pretty annoying but he finally
gets the Box closed and you know because
this was really a hard demonstration
task we asked people to watch their
demonstration and decide whether to keep
it or throw it away and so this person
is watching their demonstration and this
time on the first swing the robot closes
the box but then you know because the
robots just playing back the trajectory
it you know continues to like do this
thing and you ask the person like was
that a good input do you want to save it
please say no please hang up and they
say yes they say yeah sure that's great
so this is the problem that we have this
person thinks that was an amazing
demonstration of closing the box and we
have to build an algorithm that can deal
with learning how to close this box with
that kind of terrible data so this
motivated bearish Atkins thesis work on
thinking about this problem of you know
people that are good at show or maybe
not so good at showing you how to
achieve the skill but are actually very
good or everybody was is pretty good at
showing you what you're trying to do and
so so achieving the skill is what we
think of as the goal and exactly how to
do it is what we think of as the action
so the the showing me that I'm trying to
close the box is pretty easy to show but
showing me exactly how I should move my
seven degree of freedom arm may be hard
for some people to do and so in this
work we split those two things up and we
think about how we can
build you know two separate models
because we know that one of for some
people some of this information might be
noisy and not good so we're going to
treat these as two separate learning
problems and on the one hand I'm gonna
build an action model that's telling me
how to execute some skill but then the
objective or the goal is something I
should be using to actually monitor that
execution and so here's what we'd like
to have a little hard to see but so we'd
like to have a robot that can execute
something and then monitor that
execution and say I think that was
successful or I think that I failed and
that's going to be what we actually want
to get out of these two pieces of
information the the what to do and
exactly how to do it and so in in this
framework we have keyframe
demonstrations that are coming in and
we're gonna build an action model out of
the motor data and we're gonna have an
external sensor in this case we're using
a camera a depth camera that's looking
at the visual scene of the workspace and
building a goal a separate goal model
that can monitor that execution and and
lead to our whole process and so we call
this goal based learning from
demonstration and now what we really
like about keyframes now is that these
are not just an easy way for people to
provide robust information but these are
actually salient points in the skill so
it's actually great information for a
goal model because people are saying you
know this is an important point that's
an important point and this is another
important point so you're sort of giving
a nice demonstration of what the goal
trajectory is through the space
yeah and even uh-huh yeah so and across
different people they might be slightly
different and you know it for a single
skill somebody might give four key
points another person might give six and
it doesn't matter so much as you'll see
cuz we're gonna build a hidden Markov
model that you know if if there's two
points that are close enough together
they'll kind of get thrown into the same
hidden state and it'll be fine yeah so
I'll get into the details but yeah but
those are two separate models so we have
two separate temporal models one is
doing stuff and the other one is
monitoring but they're both learned from
the same the same demonstration yeah
yeah that's a great question
we haven't done that and I think that
it's gonna be different for different
tasks but even in the same task we don't
see people there there's some agreement
on you know if you're pouring something
yours gonna be a keyframe right before
you turn and then you don't and so you
know so there's some things that that
are common across everyone but then you
know some people just divide up the
skill a lot more and some people you
know some people forget and like go here
go here and then you don't have a very
and if you don't have that intermediate
point you're gonna start pouring like in
the middle and so so those are some of
the things that you see that are
different across people but I think
that's a great question whether there's
something that makes for a canonical
keyframe okay so I'll tell you a little
bit about what the exact data is that
we're using as input in this case so we
have the motor data is the end effector
with respect to some target object and
so you know we have the the keyframes
that are going towards this object and
we might have a couple of different ones
you know if you're coming at the object
one way versus another way the the motor
data is gonna be transformed with
respect to the target object and this is
a 3d position and a 4d rotation so we
have seven dimensions in our motor data
in the object data we have a depth
camera that's looking down at the
workspace and extracting features mostly
related to features about the bounding
box and then also features about the
surface normals of the of the from the
depth camera and so we take both of
these feature vectors and pass them
through and build different models we
are using the same algorithm but we
build two different ones so we're using
hidden Markov models and in a sense what
we get out of the hidden Markov model
after we've learned is is sort of this
canonical keyframe so you can think
about if you take several demonstrations
and you build a hidden Markov model then
these hidden state
do sort of represent the the canonical
key frames that are represented in your
data and the difference between the
action and the goal model is that we
have different emission spaces of these
states so in the in the motor space this
is a multi-dimensional is a seven
dimensional Gaussian and in the visual
space as much bigger dimensions and so
we'll take multiple demonstrations of
keyframes and use the BOM melts out
algorithm to kind of build this in a
very pretty standard way the difference
that we do is we we do add some notion
of prior States and terminal States so
we want to be able to think about
whether the that you know these are the
states that you're going to be starting
in and you know it has to reach this
state in order to consider the skill is
finished and so we have some notion of
the likelihood of different states being
starting States and terminal States
yeah we just used a Bayesian information
criterion to to come up with K mm-hmm
and I think yeah there's yeah so we use
Bayesian information criterion and when
we go to generate we do look a little
bit at the that we're generating at
least as many as the at least as many
keyframes as the minimum number that you
saw in the demonstration okay so when we
go to execute we can take our learned
action model and we can sample a path
from prior States to terminal States and
and then we are so here's where we're
when we're sampling the most likely path
from prior to terminal we're going to
favor path links that are close to the
average number of demonstrated keyframes
and then once we have a path I look at
the emission space of these states and
if I'm trying to generate the canonical
trajectory that my action model is
representing then I'm actually going to
just take the the true means of these
emission spaces and I'm taking those as
my key frames and what we do is a fifth
order spline between them to create this
trajectory that is sort of smooth and
has minimum jerk and goes between the
means of of this of these states and so
now I have this this trajectory that
I've decided is the thing that I want to
do based on the action that I learned
now I can talk about how I can use the
goal model to monitor that and so so
here's our you know we've we've sampled
our action model we've got our you know
four keyframes and we're splined between
them and now I've got this action model
up here and what I'm gonna do is while
I'm while I'm executing the action I'll
take a snapshot of of the visual space
that coincides with each of these
keyframes
and I can ask now I can take this as a
sequence in the goal space and ask my
goal model like how likely is it that
this sequence visual of my visual space
represents a success or a failure in in
the goal and so this is just kind of a
typical question that you would ask the
hmm is this is this a likely sequence
from for this model and the only
difference is that we do make sure that
the that the last frame represents
something in a terminal stage because
otherwise you could get a really likely
sequence but you only kind of halfway
did the skill so this is the whole this
is the whole system and so now we can
ask you know how well does this work
with data that we get from people so we
had eight people come and try to teach
the this robot how to close the box and
how to pour something into from a cup
into a bowl and
what they did
[Music]
okay so that is the what the
demonstrations look like and again we're
taking from this one or from the single
set of demonstrations building these two
models and and we then after the person
leaves we execute their model their
learned model five times to get a sense
of well how successful was the execution
and then while we're executing their
action model five times we can test the
goal model and say well how successful
is the goal model it's saying whether or
not the action model was was good or bad
and this is what barish had to do a lot
of times for every user
at least the robot knows that is in dual
bearish had to pick up a lot of macaroni
because as we talked about people are
not very good at it modeling exactly how
to do things but they're pretty good at
modeling the goal yeah has a different
orientation is that the most salient
observation that made action possible
that made the action possible well so
it's it's hard to say exactly because
this is this is a particular user in the
study so of the eight users this is one
one users exact skill that was learned
from several demonstrations of the skill
so that goal model is based on whatever
variants they showed in that set of four
or six or I can't remember exactly how
many demonstrations it was but you know
we're building a single hidden Markov
model from that person's data and so the
the exact dimensions that they
demonstrated variance in are what are
going to get captured in that hidden
Markov model but what we see is that
across people and I think that might be
my next slide but across across people
you know of those eight people the
clothes the Box skill had about having
you know less than 60% execution success
but more than 90% monitoring success so
the mark the hidden Markov model that
you build from somebody's demonstrations
are not very good at generating the
skill successfully but that same set of
demonstrations gave you a good
description of the goal and so same with
the pouring skill only about 75%
accuracy on actually doing the skill but
more than ninety percent in determining
whether you were good or you were
succeeding or failing at doing it
they sort of decide whether he failed or
succeeded so can you build a loop that
he can sort of start teaching himself
yes yes we can we're gonna do that and
so we see that some teachers are better
at than others at teaching actions so
some people are good at doing actions
and goals but but the the on average
people are better at teaching the goal
than teaching exactly how to do it and
so we want to bridge this gap by adding
some autonomy yes sure the goal of state
the goal is a trajectory the goal is a
trajectory that is recognized in a very
kind of standard activity recognition
sort of way with this hidden Markov
model yeah sorry
that was a good point so now we want to
self-improve based on the fact that we
have this objective function that we're
pretty confident in but we have this
action model that we're pretty
unconfident in and so what we're gonna
do is execute based on our action model
but with some variance and then we can
use our goal model to tell us when we've
executed in a good way or a bad way and
and we so we then can have the self
improvement signal that's going they
were adding a link in our model so how
are we going to execute with variants
well we're gonna do the same sort of
thing that we did when we were executing
our action model originally and but
remember before we just took and splined
in between the the exact means or the
canonical version of our of what our
action model is representing but now
instead we're gonna take this
multivariate Gaussian and use that as a
sampling mechanism so we're gonna sample
both the state paths through the hidden
Markov model and the actual omission of
each of each state which remember each
of these emission spaces is representing
a seven dimensional pose of the
end-effector
so I'm going to take and instead of
doing the canonical pose that this
action model represents I'm going to
kind of perturb some of the poses in a
particular way yeah
just position effectively you don't know
yeah so it's just it's just the position
and orientation of the end-effector with
respect to the target yeah
yeah so yeah so I'll tell you a little
bit about we we I think there's much
more we can do to sample this space more
intelligently I think we're not doing
the the best right now we have we have
what I'll show you in a second we we do
it kind of randomly but you know
weighted by the Gaussian the mixture of
gaussians but and then what we do is we
want to sort of sample broader as and we
want a sample further away from the mean
when we are either bored and we feel
like we want to expand you know we
either have a good model already and we
want to broaden kind of the
applicability of that good we want to
see like okay I have a model that I can
execute five times and it always
succeeds let me see if I can perturb
that execution and still succeed and so
you kind of want to broaden your your
skill or it's a terrible skill I'm I'm
I'm failing all the time so I want to
explore farther away from the mean
because I need to fix it and so we have
an adaptive adaptive sampling method so
each rollout of the skill is an
execution of the skill by the action
model and an evaluation of that
execution by the goal model so that
execute that's one roll out of the
system so that's an A+ case and then in
an episode we would do five rollouts and
you know so in this case we had two that
the the goal model thought were
successful and three that it thought was
a failure and currently we just take the
positive examples and put them back in
with our demonstration data and then we
rebuild a new action model that now has
our original demonstrations plus these
two more that we've seen that our
positive examples you know clearly we
could be doing more by trying to take
advantage of these negative examples
yeah
addiction so we do take and use the well
so we're using the prediction model to
label this so it's not actually training
model this is not actually good training
data for the prediction model because
we've used the prediction model to train
it go inside your model not only good
prediction of our equally good and bad
prediction this is so you should be able
to compete yeah so you can take so
better things to do so
I mean yeah we haven't done anything
with that what we the the only point at
which we do update the prediction model
is if we do have a human that's there
watching this process and they are
agreeing or disagreeing with these
labels then we can use that to update
our goal model but that's the only time
that we've we've done that but it's true
yeah there we do get a likelihood it's
not just a binary you know we got a
likelihood out of that prediction so we
could try it we could use that in some
way I'm not sure what the ground truth
would be in that case okay and so one
thing that we do is we forget the
original user data after we've seen
enough positive examples because you
know some some of the original
demonstrations of what action to do were
actually so bad that it's it's ruining
your it you know it's pulling your model
in a bad direction
yeah particular task is it true that as
a human expert you really want the last
keyframe the cup to be you know center
right um so in this work we don't do
that we're looking at other ways in
which you would kind of directly
communicate some of these constraints
like the one you're talking about and
then you can try to provide these more
kind of high-level constraints to a
planner even and just say actually the
only thing you care about is that you
have to make over here like this in your
last step and then all the way through
you have to maintain this constraint so
so we're looking at that as kind of a
different in a different way I think you
know this sort of model is one where you
could try to infer those types of
constraints but we're not doing that in
this work in particular so we do have
like I said this adaptive sampling where
depending on the ratio of success over
the last few the last few executions
will expand the how risky were being in
our sampling behavior and so here are
some examples of success and failure of
closing the box and pouring and we found
that the adaptive sampling so in both
cases so the first test that we did of
this was just my grad student parish was
you know provided a purposely failing
action model for both pouring and
closing the box so he did something that
was kind of close to closing the box but
it doesn't really do it and then used
this use this exploration to fix the
model and so we found that yes it was in
fact able to fix the model and yes you
can get there faster if you do this
adaptive sampling instead of just
randomly sampling and the question that
we have after this is whether or not we
can do this with real people's data that
we so some of the people that we we saw
these failing action models from our
first user study would we have been able
to fix their models and so that's what
we did in this last in this last in the
last experiment that I'll tell you about
so in this case we're kind of putting it
all together
and the only thing that we're adding is
this bit that we were just talking about
where now while the robot is doing its
sampling we can have the teacher
actually provide labels to the goal we
can have the teacher provide labels
during execution and during recognition
to provide this verbal feedback as to
whether or not the goal model was
correct okay so we had 12 people come in
and teach the robot three skills now
they're gonna close this box and open a
box and pour and they get five
demonstrations and during the
demonstrations the robot sort of
executed the intermediate learned model
after one three and five demo so you
know after the first it's just gonna
kind of repeat the demonstration that
you just gave but after the third and
the fifth demos it does give a sense of
what the current state of the action
model is and then the person hangs
around while the robot does you know one
rollout or one episode of the sampling
process so they get to watch the robot
try to explore four five executions and
the goal output is verbalized so the
robot says I think I failed I think I
succeeded and the the human can say yes
you're right or no you're wrong and then
the person disappears and we do the self
improvement process while they're gone
for nine more episodes so this is the
whole experiment and here's
go here all right
no here yes
yeah
and so then
[Music]
so here the robots still asking how did
I do because we're still collecting the
demonstrations to build the goal model
but then when we're actually doing the
rollout or the samples
[Music]
so there we're testing our goal model
but also getting a label from the person
as to whether or not our goal model is
correct or not okay so we did this after
for each of the people and so this would
be the same this this would tell us you
know how well did the did the models do
using just the information from the
human and just just sampling with the
human and that closed the box results
were this is a little bit hard to read
but on average it was kind of similar to
what we saw before like monitoring
success so the red bars are you know
close to 90 percent and the but the
execution success on average was not as
good you know some people's execution
success was really not good at all you
know and some people learned it you know
there's a lot of variance and how well
the the action models did and so this
was you know some people got it right
away and some people didn't
pouring results were slightly more
successful and open the box was you know
very hard almost no one had a model if
you look at the blue bars almost no one
had a bought a model that was able to
execute after this interaction so what
we are gonna do from this is take and
see if it's possible to use our self
improvement to fix some of these models
that didn't turn out very well so we'll
take just some case studies of a couple
of examples from a couple of people from
the close the box skill and a couple of
people from the open the box skill and
I'll just show you the results of a
couple of these case studies so here's
participant threes close the box initial
example this is the initial model that
that after they left this is what the
robot was able to do
and so it says I think I failed which is
correct and so here's an example of the
sampling
it slightly perturbed the action model
and achieved a success
you can see that kind of perturb it in a
different direction so now so this is
sort of what the sampling process looks
like and so that's the robot just kind
of playing around and the space in which
you know the action space in which the
robot is sort of perturbing and sampling
and playing around is actually very
small so it's almost surprising that
after this process you get a skill that
consistently succeeds and so here's with
this participant the final model and and
you can run this model five times in a
row and it'll succeed every time and
this is a model that started off you run
it five times in a row and it failed
every time so so for this episode this
person we had you know after all the
demonstrations zero success where it
meaning I run it five times it fails
five times after the sampling with the
person so just after you have five
samples I run at five times that fails
every time but then after my rollouts
in about Episode four or in about
episode two of the roll outs I can have
a model that I run it five times and it
succeeds every time so I'm going to I
have a couple other exams so this gives
you a sense of actually how much the end
effect how much the the end effector
mean through my action model is changing
both in terms of the translation and the
rotation of the end effector and it's
it's it's surprisingly little that you
have to change but I'm gonna skip ahead
to show you the final results of each of
these we did five of these case studies
or we take a single person who had a
completely failing model and use their
goal model to fix their failing action
model and in all the cases we had
eventually over the nine episodes of
self learning we end up with an action
model that is fully successful so what's
exciting to me about this is that
we didn't put anything into we didn't
give the robot any information about the
objective function right so we're we're
doing this explore we're doing this
refinement process with an objective
function that was taught by people so
we're refining from the same set of
demonstrations we have an action model
that fails but we learned enough about
that action that we can create an
objective function to train that action
model to be better and so so what we saw
in in this experiment is that we were
able to do that and at least five of
these cases that we tried some of the
other cases that we didn't try that
people either already had a good enough
action model that there was nothing to
improve or they didn't have a good
enough goal model for us to do it so you
know so there's some things we have to
understand about how to get the best
goal model out of people but but we
think this is really promising and and
I'm happy to take more questions of
something or later yeah so the the
perturbations that this action model can
can handle are you know moving around
the the target object essentially
because our state is a transformation of
the end effector with respect to the
target and the but yeah so we don't have
much we don't have much general ization
of beyond that instead of teaching a
trajectory per se rather teach the
physics of the actual goal state versus
the star state like if you teach the
robot that applies pressure at the
bottom of this lid
a little close and then it can maybe
figure out their trajectory
great teaching how to use your arm
that's what do you want to use your arm
to do this yeah I mean I think that's
part of the the trade-off between what
do you want to you know how do you I
think some but I can't remember this has
come up earlier in the week and I'm
blanking on which talk it came up in but
you know the reason we want to do these
demonstrations is it's actually hard for
us to decide exactly what to write down
like that you know so we might write
down that I think it was Uncas talk we
might write down that we want you know
to apply this pressure at the at the lid
and in this direction and that may not
be all that you need to write down right
and so demonstrations are kind of a
stand-in for doing the empirical work of
like actually writing down the control
function and so so it's this trade-off
between like oh I can just give a few
demonstrations versus I can think really
hard about the physics and and write
down the control you know write down the
differential equation and so that's kind
of the constant trade-off in this in
this learning from demonstration space
yeah
yeah yeah and that gets a little bit
jeurys question - where so I think that
you know currently we're using we're
starting from the action model still and
saying like oh well you know this action
model must be in the basin of attraction
of what's optimal to do and I just need
to use my objective function to to
search around a little bit you know if
you throw away that assumption and you
say okay if I don't believe that this
action model is anywhere near the basin
of Attraction of what to do you could
still you could still try to gleam from
the objective function like what are the
core constraints of the of the task that
the subjective function is is trying to
communicate and so that's a step further
that we haven't done exactly but I think
it is encoded in the information that we
have I'm wondering about the trade off
your design choice to say that the goal
is a trajectory versus the state it
seems like maybe there's a trade-off
there that if I said the goal is being
in this state then I'm kind of being
agnostic about the procedure you use for
it yeah yeah trajectory I'm not being
agnostic but on the other hand I'm
helping you by giving you a whole
sequence of yeah yeah it's interesting
so so we're in for the goal we are
explicitly only giving these key frames
so we're assuming that something about
the way that you've decided to divide up
this skill is important and is salient
in the goal space but that is a that is
a design choice and and I think it is
true that some key frames are
superfluous right and you should not
necessarily think of them as hard
constraints and this if we're taking and
converting this goal model that has the
set of you know intermediate states and
we actually convert that to constraints
we're gonna obey those constraints and
that may be too
that may be too restrictive but
sometimes treating just the end state as
the goal we might miss something
it you know depending on the task you
might miss something that you meant to
do so I think it's a great question like
which ones are crucial but versus which
ones are just things that I told you to
do because it was on the way the human
teachers very I would imagine the first
few keyframes you see large variants but
at the very end friend like everybody
has to get the car yeah yes yeah yeah
and that and you know so in other work
we've followed up on that too it to
drive the kind of information that you
try might try to get out of people you
might say you know if you see a lot of a
variance maybe that's not even a
constraint it's like not even a thing
just don't even worry how you start and
you can ask somebody that if you see a
state that has a huge amount of variance
you just say does it even matter where I
start and you know so we've used the
kind of variance that you see in these
models to drive active learning
questions like that like should I just
throw this whole constraint away or you
know if if I if I see a really tight
variance second Avenue does it have to
be this and then you know that it does
[Applause]